Tonight, the right
going all in on
baseless conspiracy theory
that claims Taylor
Swift's relationship with Travis Kelce
and the Super Bowl
are all rigged to help
Joe Biden win the election.
This is what I think is going to happen.
There's going to be like
some type of proposal at the after
the Super Bowl is rigged for the chiefs
and then the two of these people become
it's like reached like
crazy levels of absolute fame.
And then they use that
in order to try and save Joe Biden.
Okay.
Those comments
do not come out of nowhere.
There's a whole lot about this.
In fact,
the former presidential candidate
and top Trump ally
and now a person
seemingly campaigning for VP,
the fake ramasamy tweeted,
I wonder if he's going to win
the Super Bowl next month.
And I wonder if there's
a major presidential endorsement
coming from
an artificially culturally propped up
couple this fall.
Just some wild speculation over here.
Let's see how it ages over the next
six months.
OUTFRONT now,
Basil SMIKLE, former executive
director of the New York State
Democratic Party,
and Erick Erickson, host of the popular
eponymous radio show.
Okay, Great to have both of you with us.
So, Erick, you know,
I mean, honestly, okay, this is Q
and on level,
you know, Pizzagate
conspiracy theories
that the Super Bowl is rigged
and it's all rigged
so the Chiefs last longer.
So I don't know,
she gets a little bit more famous
for making an endorsement.
I mean,
I can't even make sense of it all.
But the vague
Ramaswamy post
was in response,
actually, Erick,
to one of the promoters of Pizzagate.
Does this trouble you?
Of course it does.
And let me be clear.
First of all,
I should admit
I've been to five concerts in my life
for Taylor Swift and one Adele,
all because my daughter wanted me
to take her to these concerts.
So I get the Taylor Swift fandom
by my daughter
and so many others try to get me
to wear a Taylor Swift
sweatshirt tonight, but I didn't.
Here's what's going on.
These guys aren't actually serious,
but they know that people will
believe them.
And in the process,
they'll get talked about,
they'll get buzz.
They might be able to cash
in and grift on it.
They're hucksters, frauds and charlatans
who are whipping people into a frenzy
about something they don't even believe
because they think it's funny
to go viral and get attention
and maybe convince
some people who aren't very bright
that it's happening in the process.
You've got Cori
Bush investigated
by the Justice Department today,
and the right's not talking about that.
They're talking about
the most popular woman on the planet
dating the most popular
titan in the NFL,
in the most popular sport on the planet.
And they're just stupid.
I mean, so that's what I mean.
Look, here's the thing about this
and just trying to understand
what they think they're getting or what
who they're convincing about, what.
I mean, Taylor Swift
endorsed Joe Biden in 2020.
In 2018,
she actually endorsed
the Democrat running
against the Republican senator,
Marsha Blackburn,
in her home state of Tennessee.
By the way, I didn't do anything there.
In Taylor Swift's documentary,
she talks about why she got involved
in that particular race. Here she is.
This from
So you think
Taylor Swift comes out against Trump?
I don't care how they write that.
I'm sad that I didn't two years ago,
but I can't change that.
I'm saying right now
that this is the thing
that I know is right.
And you guys,
I need to be
on the right side of history.
And she doesn't win that.
At least I at least I tried.
All right.
You know, she then reacted
when Marsha Blackburn actually won.
She called her Trump in a wig.
Okay, I'm saying this
because we know where she stands, though.
She's clear about where she stands.
I don't know who is ambiguous about where
she stands on Trump right now.
Why is there a conspiracy over this?
You know, I have no idea.
You know,
I don't understand
the Taylor Swift phenomenon.
If it was short, a different story,
I'd have a reaction.
But I don't understand the Taylor Swift
phenomenon in this regard.
You know, when we talk about Pizzagate,
there were real world reactions to this.
People were harassed.
People got hurt.
And my sense
is that what they're trying to do,
as we said
before, is to get Trump's
supporters to react
and hope that that translates into a vote
and suppression of other votes.
In terms of in terms
of both harassment and intimidation.
Right.
My but again, my concern
is that this actually has real world
consequences.
This is just not theory right
now, number one.
And number two, how petty is this?
You don't have any policies to run on.
You don't have a legislative agenda
that you can run on as a Republican.
So you want to make sure that these
these
these conspiracy theories
get pushed out in some hope
to kind of fill the void,
the narrative void.
But what effect does it have?
All it'll do is gin up
Taylor Trump,
Taylor Swift
supporters, who are young voters
all across the country,
if that is possible,
to get them to go out
and vote against you. So why do that?
I mean, Erick, this is the thing.
I mean, it's
Taylor Swift, obviously, being who
she is
as an inspiration to many young women.
Now, you've got
some of the women who work with Trump
taking shots at Taylor Swift.
So, again,
I don't totally understand this,
but Alena have a post.
She shared a post on Instagram.
The post she shared says,
who thinks this country needs
a lot more women
like Elina Haba and a lot
less like Taylor Swift.
And then Trump's national press
secretary said this on HANNITY
last night.
Let's not forget that Taylor Swift
has made a career off of writing songs
about picking the wrong man.
So I don't think
we should take advice from her now.
You know, Eric actually
got real perspective on this
because your daughter is a Taylor
Swift fan.
Do do these women who work for Trump
coming out and saying this
and behaving this way,
does that fall on receptive ears
on young women
who just happen
to like Taylor Swift as an entertainer?
You know, maybe some.
But I mean, go back to Tennessee.
She endorsed Marsha Blackburn's opponent.
It didn't help.
A lot of people think for themselves.
And the only people who apparently don't
think for themselves
are the people listening
to these hucksters, frauds and grifters
they think they can persuade.
And, you know, to the other point,
there could be real world consequences.
You know, the
the Pizzagate grifters
who are the same guys pushing this.
I actually encourage people
to show up at that pizza restaurant.
And they did.
It's it's insanity
that they're playing with fire.
And also many of these same guys
just six weeks ago were saying
Taylor Swift was a curse to the
to the chiefs
because they weren't doing so
well at the time.
They're just trying
to get viral attention
and they don't care what the fallout is.
It's a nihilism
that's creeped into the right
of deeply unserious people.
It is it is deeply unserious, Basil.
And and there could be serious
implications to that.
Trump himself, though, has as previously,
you know, slam Taylor Swift
when when
when he came out
when she came out against him in 2018
and then also this fall,
he tells the Daily CALLER,
I wish the best for both of them
talking about her and Kelsey.
I hope they enjoy their life.
Maybe together, maybe not.
Most likely not.
Crazy.
Again, how petty is this?
Do you have nothing else to talk about
but Taylor Swift? And who's she?
Who she's dating right now?
But look
at the end of the day,
endorsements
may not mean a heck of a lot.
A percentage here and there.
Right. Right.
However,
one of the things that I remember
from the Obama
campaign and experience
is that you had all these celebrities
encouraging their supporters to go out
and vote.
The chatter,
the buzz that they can create
is worth millions.
So all you're doing is elevating her
and elevating that buzz and that chatter.
Why do that?
What's your perspective?
All right. Well, thank you both.
So glad to see you both.